a major political showdown in Georgia
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
squared off in their only scheduled
debate last night early voting for
midterm elections begins Monday in
Georgia this closely watched contentious
race between the Reverend and the former
running back could decide control of
Congress Nicole Killian is in Savannah
and joins us now Nicole good morning
hey good morning to you Dana
representatives from both campaigns feel
pretty good about how things went after
a policy-packed debate that was full of
fireworks and props
the southern hospitality quickly wore
off this race is about who's ready to
represent the people of Georgia as a
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock at GOP
Challenger Herschel Walker retreated to
their Corners he's for Joe Biden I'm for
Georgia clashing over everything from
the economy crime and education to
voting rights and abortion rights I
believe in life and I tell people this
Georgia is a state that respects life
and I'll be a senator that protects life
he says no exceptions even in the case
of rape
incest
or the life of the mother I think that's
extreme Walker was also confronted again
about reports he allegedly paid for a
woman's abortion in 2009. that's a lie
my opponent has a problem with the truth
the Freshman Senator two came at other
claims by his opponent including that he
once worked in law enforcement one thing
I have not done I've never pretended to
be a police officer I am with minute
police officers and you have a prop that
is not allowed sir I ask you to put that
prop away the candidate's personal
issues were also thrust into the
spotlight as Warnock was questioned
about child support payments to his
ex-wife
listen I um I went through a divorce
like a lot of people my children know
that I am with them and for them and
that I support them in every single way
that a father does while Walker was
pressed about accusations of abuse
against his ex I've been very
transparent and I'm not ashamed to admit
it and I said I had a mental problem
Walker said he has overcome his mental
illness and believes he is ready to
serve as for that badge a campaign
representative tells us that it was an
honorary badge from a local Department
Walker is campaigning here in Savannah
this morning while warn up will
participate in another debate tomorrow
although Walker is not expected to
attend Michelle
Nicole quite a show thank you